hands up guys my name is achernar and
welcome back to my c++ series so you're
using linux to develop sigilyph lost
code okay cool let's cover how we can
set up the tools we need on linux so
that we can make c++ programs now of
course there are so many different tools
out there so many different ways to
write and build your code I'm going to
cover one of those ways one that I
personally like I hope you're ready to
do some serious setting up I mean you've
chosen Linux so obviously you're going
to be prepared to do some work basically
we're going to use C mag to generate
project files for an IDE called code
light code light is a nice lightweight
IDE that basically does pretty much
everything you would expect but isn't
too heavy weight and just lets us write
our code in a nice way so let's go ahead
and set everything up so we've got a
VirtualBox VM here running Mint 18.1 and
I'm using KDE as my GUI so if I go ahead
and open a terminal we can get started
the first thing I like to do is set up a
directory here called dev which is
basically going to hold all of our
development stuff
we'll make and then basically inside
here we'll have a like a folder for each
project so I'll make a directory for
follow world which is going to be what
we're going to do here now we're going
to set up a basic hello world project
now in terms of the applications that we
actually have to install we basically
need the ones that we really need are a
compiler C make and code light for the
first thing you're going to want to do
to install that is do sudo apt-get
update that's just going to basically
update in having your root password
that's going to basically update all of
our package packages our package
repositories and then once that's done
we can actually install the text as we
need so what we need our will do apt-get
install I'll excuse them is my terminal
text editor and then we'll get your plus
plus ago profiler will get coded lights
as our IDE and we will get a C make and
then just hit answer instead of taking a
hundred ninety eight megabytes Y and
this will take a while okay so once that
is done let's go ahead and clear this so
we've got nothing in our directory right
now I like to make a directory called
source and that's where I'll actually
put all of my source files I'm going to
just create a file in the source
directory called main just a BB and just
now I'm going to write anything into it
I'm just going to create the empty file
and will actually let code light handle
that file for us we're going to need to
set up the C make file and then I also
like to set up a build script so that
we've got an easy way to generate a
project so in terms of C may make that
first I'm just going to use them you can
use any text editor you like the file is
going to be called C make list dot txt
and it's going to basically just
instruct they make how we want to
actually generate our code like project
file so first of all we'll specify a
minimum version of C make that we need
as a good rule of thumb I like to just
roll with version 3.5 will then give our
project a name so I'll just hollow world
and then we'll set up some variables
eventually so intensive like flags that
we want to use for compilation we want
to use the existing one so that
basically C 50 C makes the xx legs which
are the compilation apply um but in
terms of what we actually want to do we
want to add up we want to display all
warning errors of course and then
intensive like which standard library we
use you can use people as weapons at
once but it doesn't really doesn't
really matter for this project since
we'll be just using will be printing
hello world but I'm looking over 14
years future profiles a little bit we're
creative variable here called source
directory and I'll actually set it to be
the project forth directory and then
essentially just a folder called source
so the printer source directory is the
directory we're currently in and then
inside there I'm just thinking I've just
made a directory called source and
that's where all my source files are so
that works out pretty well so we've set
up these variables right those two lives
were just variables we've set our flags
and we set our source directory now we
actually need to somehow tell the
compiler which files to compile so again
we're using CMake we can just use a
globe for that so basically I'm going to
specify that my source files are going
to be in that source directory and that
source writer is just as variable that
I've made up here right and then
basically anything inside that directory
that ends in C++ typically I want to
compile now if you had include
directories and stuff you would also
want to set that up but so now we're not
going to do that we'll just add
executables this is going to be our
target
the HelloWorld is a project name and
then which files we want to pop into
they are going to be our source files if
you had again an include directory or
something you would also pop it in here
but there we go
that's all of our stuff that's that's
our entire cmakelists done so let's
write and quit now we'll set up a script
that will run CMake for us so I'll call
this build door Sh now this isn't really
going to build our code it's just going
to generate the project and I'll show
you kind of how the collapse in a minute
but basically the first thing we want to
do is make sure that Bash is going to be
able to get it in the lab so we'll add
bin FH as every bash script we'll have
then we'll do C make dash G so in terms
of the target we're going to be using
code light UNIX make file vision or
something like ninja if you like
probably a bit better than this because
it's to be a setup and then as far as my
build type goes I'm actually going to
set that to debug mostly make the build
type because
generating a debug configuration is
probably what we want anyway since we'll
be debugging a lot and you want to make
sure the code light has a capital L here
and that's it we can write and quit that
and that's out it's gonna be our entire
script is very very simple so now we're
ready to run our script now in order to
run a script in Linux you have to market
it as executable so we'll just do chmod
plus x and then build Sh so we're just
adding the executable flag to the build
Sh
now we can run it and hopefully if you
did everything correctly you can see
that it's written some build files for
us so if we look at the directory
because it is a number of new files here
the ones that we kind of care about our
hello world a project hello world up for
workspace there are make files as well
but you can see that those kind of the
important so now how do we open this in
code light well I like to just open it
through the terminal so you can just
type in code light and then hello world
sort workspace now if you want to open
it in the background so you can still
use your terminal just add an ampersand
on to the end hit enter and code light
should open now you're probably going to
want to run through the setup I don't
really care to my hair Council as you
can see we've got our project here and
our target which makes a bit bigger
we've got our include directories so
this is where all of our includes go
it's also just going to go in here we'll
double click the file to open it I'm
going to just basically type out a
simple hello world application
so we'll say and we'll do our little
standoff yet as well alright save that
you want to build it you can just hit
build and build projects outputs down
here and you can see that everything's
fine there are errors zero warnings
we're ready to go so go back to terminal
and I do an LS you can see we've got a
holo world
file and it's actually executable
right so that's our actual program so
let's go ahead and run that Lego hello
world we've written our first
application if you want to run it inside
here one thing I like to do is just go
to preferences and make it used to
built-in terminal emulator and then you
can just do build run we can build it
and execute it and you can see here it
is running inside of code light all
right that's it Linux is setup we're
ready to write some code we're ready to
learn some C++ over the next two videos
we're going to cover how people Claus
actually works because that's the key to
learning how to write C++ properly until
then you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and if you really like this
series you can support my videos by
pledging on patreon.com for clash to
channel until next time goodbye warm